THE GLORY DAYS:
Remember Sprint? 10-15 years ago,
Sprint was one of the big 3 telecom companies
along with AT&T and Verizon. They had tens of
millions of subscribers and were pulling in tens
of billions of dollars. But by the end of the
decade, the picture looked a lot different. Not
only was Sprint bleeding subscribers and revenue,
but they were being shown up by a new player: T
Mobile. T Mobile had risen from the ashes of near
bankruptcy and was making a name for themselves
as the “uncarrier”. Everything that you hated
about cell phone plans and carriers, T
Mobile eliminated. No more contracts,
no more hidden fees, and no more sleazy salesmen.
And this pitch worked. It worked really well
actually. Within just a few years, T Mobile would
grow from being a distant player behind Sprint to
trying to acquire the entirety of Sprint. This
was definitely a punch to the gut for Sprint and
likely a deal that they did not want to accept.
But looking inwards at the fundamentals of Sprint,
it was obvious that T Mobile was making a generous
offer and turning it down would be a disservice to
shareholders. So, in 2018, Sprint would agree
to a $26.5 billion deal with T Mobile. It took
a few years to actually finalize the deal and get
in through regulators but eventually on April 1,
2020, T Mobile would complete their acquisition of
Sprint. At first, there was some hope that maybe
T Mobile would keep around the Sprint branding and
just operate at as a subsidiary like they did with
Boost Mobile. But, T Mobile immediately moved to
wipe away all remnants of Sprint. And just a few
months after the acquisition on August 2, 2020,
the Sprint brand would be officially discontinued.
With the help of Sprint, T Mobile has become the
largest telecom company in the US, and revenue
has exploded to a new tier, so things are going
better than ever. But, the same cannot be said
about Sprint. If you try accessing Sprint.com,
you’re met with this sad landing page that just
redirects you to the T Mobile website. But, how
did this happen? How did Sprint go from being one
of the big 3 telecom companies to being completely
erased off the face of the planet within a matter
10 years? Well, join me, as we take a look back at
the rise and fall of the forgotten giant: Sprint.
THE UNDERDOG:
Sprint was obviously left behind largely
because of their unwillingness to change with the
times. Their story is particularly interesting
because unlike their peers, they didn’t came from
a monopolistic background. If you didn’t know,
AT&T and Verizon both evolved from the original
AT&T which at their peak controlled 90% of the
US telephone business. Similarly, T Mobile has
very much benefitted from the backing of Deutsche
Telecom, Germany’s national telecom carrier.
Sprint, however, has always been the underdog
as the story of Sprint dates back to 1899 to
the rural town of Abeline, Kansas to a man
named Cleyson Leroy Brown. Cleyson was the sone
of Jacob Brown, a local grist mill owner. Usually,
this would’ve led to a pretty nice upbringing
but unfortunately for Cleyson, his father’s
mill turned out to be his worst nightmare as
he would lose his arm to a mill accident when
he was just 10 years old. Cleyson didn’t let this
accident wear him down though. He would go on to
be a teacher and a manager at a creamery before
opening a local electric company that generated
electricity using the Smoky Hill River. It was
around this time that telephones first started
make their appearance across the nation, and when
it came to telephones, there was only one option:
the Bell telephone company or AT&T. The local
people of Abeline weren’t exactly a fan of
this as they much preferred supporting a local
business man as opposed to the national giant. So,
at their request, Cleyson would establish
the Brown Telephone Company in 1899, and this
brings us into the first key strategy of Sprint,
customer loyalty and connection. The reason that
the Brown Telephone Company was successful was
not because they had insane resources or some
sort of groundbreaking technology. No, the reason
that the Brown Telephone Company was successful
was because they had a personal connection with
their customers and their customers were rooting
for their victory. It was this same strategy
that T Mobile capitalized on over a 100 years
later with their whole “uncarrier” movement.
Customers were rooting for T Mobile to redefine
the carrier landscape and clean the space. The
same, however, cannot be said about the modern
Sprint. Most customers didn’t have a particularly
positive or negative view on sprint but they were
only using Sprint for one main reason: because
it made financial sense. Sprint gave them a
good deal or a strong discount which got them in
the door. When that initial promo ended though,
people would simply leave. In other words,
Sprint had very little customer loyalty and
this really hurt them. All of the new customers
that they were getting were money losers,
and right when they tried to convert them into
profitable customers, they would just leave. Aka,
each new customer was a net negative for the
company. The best way to overcome this pitfall is
to give customers a reason to stick around that’s
not just purely financial or logical similar to
what T Mobile or the Brown Telephone Company did.
Without this X factor though, Sprint simply became
the place that savvy customers farmed deals
which eventually made the company unviable.
BOTCHED DEAL:
Fortunately, things were looking much better
for Cleyson Brown back in the day. Cleyson never
had aspirations of growing some sort of national
giant. In fact, he much preferred to run a variety
of different local businesses. After founding the
Brown Telephone Company, Cleyson opened up shoe
stores, grocery stores, a gravel and sand company,
hotels, a news service, a broadcast station,
insurance companies, and oil companies. As you
can see, Cleyson was much more of a multi faceted
business man as opposed to being a magnate in
any one sector. But, this didn’t mean that he
squandered growth opportunities that did came
his way. In fact he was very much known for his
consolidation and expansion skills. In 1911 for
example, he merged the Brown Telephone company
with three other local telephone companies to
create the United Telephone Company. And in 1925,
he would further consolidate to create the United
Telephone and Electric Company. Sprint very
much kept up this tradition of strong mergers
and acquisitions well past Cleyson’s days and
this brings us into their second key strategy:
strategic deals. This is precisely how Sprint
grew from being a regional phone business to
being a national giant: consistently making
better and better deals. For example, in 1986,
Brown’s company would make a ground breaking deal
with Southern Pacific Communications or SPC. They
would agree to merge with SPC and create a new
joint venture that called Sprint which stands
for Southern Pacific Railroad Internal Networking
Telephony. Similarly, in 1993, Sprint would merge
with a cellular business called Cental which gave
them access to the wireless market. And in 1996,
they would strike a deal with Radioshack to open
up Sprint stores inside Radioshacks. Those were
just a few of Sprint’s most notable deals. They’ve
completed dozens of such deals and that’s how they
really grew their national presence, but not
all of their deals had such a happy ending
which brings us into their deal with Nextel
Communications. In 2004, Sprint announced that
they would be merging with Nextel Communications.
At the time, Sprint was the 3rd largest player
and Nextel was the 5th largest player within the
mobile phone industry. So, on paper, it seemed
that this merger would make this duo unstoppable,
but see, there’s more to a merger than just size.
For a merger to be successful, both parties need
to have significant synergies that can benefit
from each other. For example, maybe Sprint had
strong network in the east and Nextel had a strong
network in the west. Together, they could have
a strong nationwide network, but that’s not how
things quite played out. You see, not only did
Sprint and Nextel not have many synergies but they
actually had a bunch of opposing technologies
that could not be combined. As such, if the
new company wanted to streamline and consolidate
their networks, they often had to choose between
the two companies' holdings rendering the merger
completely useless. To make things worse, their
integration efforts often led to outages and cell
phone plans simply not working altogether. So,
not only did the merger not allow them to reach
new heights but it made them look bad in front of
their existing customers. Sprint would eventually
write off almost the entirety of Nextel in 2008 as
a $29.5 billion loss and they would shut down
the company altogether in 2013. Having wasted
a full decade and tens of billions on this deal,
Sprint had fallen far behind AT&T and Verizon when
it came to network coverage and reliability,
and this leads us into their eventual demise.
EGO KILLS:
By the time that Sprint shut down Nextel, things
were looking pretty bleak. They had a subpar
network with bruised morale, unloyal customers,
and an empty balance sheet. But, honestly, you
could argue that T Mobile was in an even worse
position. In fact, T Mobile wasn’t even allowed to
sell iPhones till 2013, yet they were able do this
over the next 10 years, so Sprint was by no means
a lost cause. They definitely still had a chance
to recover but staging such a recovery requires
one key characteristic: humility. This was one
of the strong suits of Cleyson. He didn’t live
a particularly long life having passed away at
age 63, but despite that, he spent the latter
half of his life giving back to the community
that had given him everything. In 1926, he built
a Memorial Foundation in memory of his parents. He
would also go onto to build a 200 acre park for
free which included an amusement park, a lake,
a zoo, a golf course, tennis courts, and more.
Of course, this has no direct link to business
but at the same time, it does. Humility is
extremely important when it comes to running
a business. It turns out that customers are
surprisingly understanding when you’re honest
about a shortcoming instead of trying to hide it
or deceive them about it. Again, this is precisely
what T Mobile leveraged. They admitted that
they sucked. They didn’t have the best service,
that was simply a fact. But, they were working
on fixing this and while they couldn’t promise
you the best service right now, what they
could promise you was an honest transparent
relationship, something that you couldn’t get from
the big players. It would’ve been in Sprint’s best
interest to leverage a similar strategy but
their ego rendered this virtually impossible.
Sprint approached the situation with the ego of
a national giant. As far as they were concerned,
they were still the big dog and they were
just facing a temporary downfall. As such,
they thought they could just pretend that they
weren’t inferior to AT&T and Verizon and just
incentivize themselves out of this situation.
You know, by offering strong discounts and deals,
but as we discussed, this just led to net
negative customers who were only there for
the incentive which is not really surprising.
After all, we’re talking about a carrier that
came with all of the same shortfalls as AT&T
and Verizon. You know, the 2 year contracts,
the hidden fees, and the sleazy sales people. But,
the network wasn’t even good either meaning that
the only reason to stick around was for financial
incentives. So, trying to buy customers wasn’t
exactly a great long term strategy. To make
things worse, given that Sprint never really
admitted that they had a problem, they never
addressed their shortcomings. For example,
they decided against building traditional
cell towers for some reason. Similarly,
they were relatively late to 5G, something
that T Mobile was early to. And when you
combine this lack of customer loyalty
with a botched deal that’s weighing down
the company and a general unwillingness
to admit shortcomings and overcome them,
Sprint’s fate was sealed long before T Mobile
actually took over and put them down for good.
If you would like to see how T Mobile managed to
do what Sprint couldn’t, check out this video.